wir holen die einfach günstig 60
jawohl wir können uns mitmachen längst
über links und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute mal in jump muss
kurzmann haben wir dem kopfhörerkabel
runter bestellen denn wir haben heute
ein gast den bekennen manche von euch
heut ist ein guter kumpel von max und er
hatte damals auch ein youtube kanal mich
würde interessieren wer von euch kennt
noch sein youtube kanal
falls sie dennoch kennt schreibt man den
namen in die beschreibung für ihn
interessieren sollte was heute machen
lasst mich nicht um den brei herumreden
sowie ein wie sowie zwei köche bei einer
konversation verstehst du warum den brei
herum
ja die stehe halt auch um den brei
herumreden ja umbringen
ok weiter und zwar habe ich letztens mit
max in einem livestream letztens ist
welche dienste dienst da genau sonntag
im livestream der übrigens richtig cool
war dank an alle die dabei waren habe
ich maximal der uni get down gespielt
und haben mit namen hat maximal am ende
setzte sich selbst sich so ein kran ii
sagt ausgedacht im live stream sowie
abzusprechen aber die ganze befehle
gegeben aber einer war ziemlich cool und
zwar der dass er im deathmatch die maus
steuert ich die tastatur hatte wir waren
damit eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich gut
aber das problem ist ich bin eigentlich
vor litauen 0
da kriege ich keine gestalten dennoch
nicht ich muss ein bisschen üben und
deswegen machen wir genau diese
challenge heute aber in jump liegt denn
ich habe eigentlich für meine
verhältnisse
ich wollte sagen nizza kampik gebracht
aber war ich gestern erstmals komplett
absurd aber leute ihr wisst was ich
meine ich habe zu wenig dunkel gebracht
ich darf meine heimat spiel hauptspiel
modus nicht untreu werden und deswegen
heute mal diese jump we change und halte
ich fest im deathmatch wird auf jeden
fall sehr chaotisch zugehen denn dann
spielt der rheinländer level hab schon
die maus oder im winter kein minecraft
mehr gespielt ja das kommt noch
erschwerend dazu nicht nur das jetzt wie
wir uns das aufteilen sondern hat
einfach ewigkeiten schon kann minecraft
mehr gespielt hat zwar ab wie lange war
es ungefähr
so zwei drei monate bestimmt alter wie
kannst du nur
es gibt leute können es nachvollziehen
ein halber kraft spielen kann was du
hast zu tun
minecraft geht vor mitglied forderte
umgekehrt abgesehen dass doch noch die
kiste war so schön mitgenommen wie der
hier sowieso nicht diesen spielmodus
nehmen wie man die maps gerettet werden
die einzelmodule eichmann wie die
bewährte funktionen zustande kommt es
nach dem nein oder das thema wenn das
immer so kurz
da ist einfach ein bauer der diese map
erbaut und dann setzt setzt sich der
hohe rat von clementi zusammen das sind
alles so leute um die 80 was sage ich um
die 80 um die 110 mit grauem werten und
design an dieses modul weist eine
überaus hohe schwierigkeit auf wir
werden es mit dem attribut hart bewerten
so funktioniert das
das war die ganze geschichte und jetzt
müssen wir kurz davor gucken gucken dass
kurz vor gucken und es gibt heute eine
besondere ankündigung zu machen
zwar hätte das ding es ist was mit der
post gekommen und etwas was gar mit der
post gekommen ist heute hat mich
durchaus gefreut drop the bass ist es
wofür es ganz ohne wirz heute ich bin
verrate wie passt aber ich habe mich
extrem gefreut über dieses teil also
wirklich ihr mich wie ein
honigkuchenpferd habe ich nicht
gestanden
und ja ich bin da sein oder wird also
ich hab mich echt richtig gefreut als
das ding heute kam obwohl ich die 100000
hab's ja schon eine weile habe seit
november und mittlerweile sogar schon
150000 was total krass ist es geht
einfach irre schnell dankeschön dafür
noch mal leute ich weiß nich bedanke
mich jeden tag 3000 mal
aber muss man auch machen okay das ist
das letzte modul nein als ob ich das
dann eben springe
das ist eine schwächere module das kann
ich nicht so gut aber kommen wir müssen
die die abu zinscash springt stalter der
stadt einfach instant da kommt schon die
leute gehört haben wären keine wut wir
können ganz kurz mein leben frauen ist
jetzt auch award.com passen rein was
links liegt auf den kompass im kompass
der ok ok level 1 0 machen dann muss ein
bisschen show new project object of
economic affairs waren zu viele
woher kommt einer aua aua orga teams
bekommen ohne einen obertor des verkaufs
ausdruck zurück da kommt wieder einer
egal ob sie darauf auf ihn drauf der
merkt sich das gespann protection einer
wie viel los
ich habe 23 kills nein es läuft jetzt
einfach die gabi canales es geschafft
habe ich mir ja ja 4 kids kommt jetzt
von mir wir haben ihn wir haben mit 9 1
x gold und wie ok wir mal umdrehen da
immer mehr immer im kopf macht draußen
versteckt sich ein
ich habe ja sehr schön
die sache ist nämlich das ist ja so
intuitiv straith leute dich glaubst du
nach links nach rechts und raul
weisheiten darauf klar kommen und welche
richtung ich laufe vielleicht laufe ich
einfach gerade auf den gegner zu du
klickst einfach durch das hatte das war
doch mal was
rechts kann davon wir wollen für eine
beziehung
wir holen die einfach günstig
jawohl wir können uns mitmachen links
und links rüber linksblocks river gold
corp ist aber okay ich ja ja ok warte
jetzt auf die templeton rein ja wohl
jetzt kräftig platzieren aber hewitt hat
ja auch verlaufen habe ich zudem gegen
oder gar nicht wie du mich nicht falsch
wir haben das eisenstädter dams
millimeter heißt auch wir jetzt sterben
leute
wir haben unser eisen schwert auflaufen
ich weiß wie sie gemacht junge ok
gericht jetzt gleich ins emmental ja
wohin uns ist eine das inventar und dann
gehst du mit der maus schnell auf das
eisen schwert ja hayes überweisen
schwert die maus okay dann drücke ich
die einzelnen passwort 1 okay okay alles
gut und erwarte lauf weiter vor gott und
gott lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf lochbihler
auf den folgetagen okay wir müssen noch
mal drehen kommt eine jetzt auf
busreisen spricht drüber liegt es da
unser einzige weg ist da und da ich kann
das in folge nahm wurde
wir hatten das inventar als ob der
andere das hatte rechtsklick jungen ein
mord der das wenigstens den schaden
jetzt das geht nicht es geht
nein dieses kataster genau deswegen wird
genau dass wir haben ein platziertes tnt
platziert einfach den schalter die junge
frau ich hasse dich gemacht man alles
gute
schade wir haben wert verloren
zu ärgerlich aber so ist das mit den
challengers die change wenn ihr euch
gefallen hat